- Welcome back to Kevin Hart's
The Kelly Clarkson Show.
And guess what?
This is a tribute to Rad Dads.
Oh my God would Rad Dads they are.
- They are.
- Yeah, give me some.
- Well, Kevin did actually
want to honor some amazing dads
and that absolutely
describes my next guest.
He's a single father of four boys.
And this spring, the family was devastated
when a fire tore through their
home, they lost everything.
They're now living out of a motel
and here to talk about it is Troy.
So say hi to Kevin, Troy.
- Hi, Kevin.
- Hey, what's going on, man?
- Not much.
He's like just hanging out.
Well, why don't you start this
off since you're, you know,
It's Kevin Hart's show.
- Troy, I mean, look.
First of all, welcome to the Kevin Hart's
The Kelly Clarkson show.
It's a tribute to Rad Dads, man.
- Thank you.
- Guess what?
You fit the mold, sir, which
is why we're talking to you.
How's everybody doing?
- Yeah. Everybody's safe.
And that's the biggest thing of that.
- Yeah, that's a major blessing.
So before we get to that
you already had a tough
year as a family, right?
- Oh yeah. We've been devastated.
You know, I was doing home
theaters, custom home theaters
and COVID hit and I lost my
job, without unemployment.
Then the distance schooling happened
and we're all at home.
And I think just the stress of income
and my kids not going to regular school,
I think all that stress, I
ended up having back to back
heart attacks.
- Wow.
- And I think somebody up there
just want me to stick around for my boys.
Cause you know, I'm all they have.
- Man, I can't. Two back-to-back,
that's a lot of stress on not only you,
but your boys as well.
So can you tell us,
how did the fire start?
Do you know?
- I found out later it
was an electrical panel,
faulty electrical panel.
That's what the fire chief
said, fire marshall or somebody.
- Wow. So what do you want?
Do you want to ask anything, Kevin?
- Well, you know, I mean the
one thing that you just said
that was really amazing, man.
You said you're a walking miracle.
I think that's not only correct
but that's an amazing thing
for you to understand and realize.
Are you taking that
energy that you now have
and are you putting it all
into your kids at this point?
- Yeah, I mean right now,
I'm in limbo right now
because we're living
in a single room motel.
So I'm doing everything I possibly can,
still healing from my heart attack,
but I take the kids to the
park, I take them swimming.
Cause you know, being confined
in a motel all the time,
it's really trying on
these poor kids, you know?
So I'm still doing the best I can
in the situation that I'm in.
- I mean, that's gotta be
incredibly difficult too
because we just saw the picture
of your boys and their ages.
They're in school so
they've obviously been doing
online school probably as well. Right?
- Yeah. Distance learning.
Now that we're doing it in a motel room,
it's really trying.
I got somebody in the bathroom,
somebody in the closet,
somebody on the bed, you know,
maybe somebody is out in the car
trying to do their distance learning.
It's really hard right now.
We're in a bad situation. It's horrible.
- Yeah. Well, can you tell
us more about your boys?
They seem pretty resilient
with you, I sort of heard.
- My oldest, he's kind of
my genius nerdy scientist.
He's always coming up with something new.
I got my 11 year old Steven, he's autistic
and he's like just so smart in school.
He's like the top of his
class in math and in reading.
And then I have Max, who is my caregiver.
Makes sure I take my medication.
He's always cleaning.
He's always gotta be matching clothes.
And then my youngest seven-year-old,
he's my little Tasmanian devil.
He's always off the hook.
Always wants to be the
ham dancing for anybody.
I mean, they all got
their own personality.
- Also with us is Troy, a a
single father of four boys
who was currently homeless
after a devastating house fire.
His boys, Charles, Steven,
Max, and Leo are also with us.
Welcome you guys.
I like that blue shirt.
Oh, you all look so good.
What's up fellas, how you doing?
- Good.
- All right. All right.
Well let me ask you all something.
Has the community really
stepped up to help?
I heard they have.
- The community here in
Vallejo is so amazing.
I've had people come to my hotel room,
bring us home cooked meals,
bring us brand new clothing
for me and my children.
And some of these people didn't look like
they had the money to even give.
And that's the most touching
thing of this whole community.
It's been wonderful.
- Wow. Well you want to take it from here?
- First of all, that's an amazing look
and family that you have, man.
A bunch of handsome boys that I see.
Guys, you know, I think
that you should be so lucky,
so lucky to truly understand
what this moment is about right now.
And it's about your dad
just being so brave,
so tough to stand in what he's standing in
and realize that he's not
only doing it for you guys,
but he's doing it for himself.
And I love that.
Like you guys right now have just kind of
amplified my energy and just
putting a warmer feeling
and spirit in my heart.
And I don't know if you noticed or not,
but today, this is Kevin
Hart's The Kelly Clarkson Show,
so, you know, for me hosting
or like my first big day here,
this is a bigger moment for me.
And I'm gonna give you guys
something that never happens.
I'm going to give you a
little bit of my drums.
Can we hand in one real quick please?
Hit them.
(heavy drum roll)
- He doesn't give that away.
- I wanna change
the light movement because right now
it's amplified a little more.
These boys got my energy and
my blood boiling correctly.
Give me another color, if you can guys.
- What's you all favorite color?
What's somebody's favorite color there?
- Blue.
- Red.
- Blue? Let's go back
to the electric blue.
- Back to electric blue for the boys.
- Let's do it.
Blue is my favorite.
- Back to the electric
blue with the boys. Hit em.
(heavy drum roll)
- And it's so sweet that y'all
really are understanding.
I was just, you know,
listening to even my producers
that were talking to you before the show,
it's really important.
Like Kevin said, everybody's understanding
this is a hard moment for
your family right now,
but the people that are
going to get you through it
are sitting right next to each other.
It's y'all and that's
why we also reached out
to Arcade 1up, the leader
in at-home entertainment
and creator of the retro
arcade games like Pacman
and Mortal Combat and Pinball
machines featuring Star Wars,
Marvel superheroes, and Attack from Mars.
They think that you are a super dad.
All right. And so they're
gonna give you $40,000
and I'm going to round
it up to even $50,000.
- Oh my God.
- That's $50,000 guys.
You know what? Hey, Kelly
would have want that. Hit 'em.
(heavy drum rolls)
- And just so you know, I
know like the guys right now
are like, "Okay, cool. That's money."
And dad's probably more
excited about that,
but that's not all, actually
Arcade 1up wants you
and the boys to have some fun as well.
So they're also giving you
a classic video game machine
of your choice, you can pick.
You can pick which one.
And then you all have something
to do other than school.
Well, thank you guys so much.
You're a beautiful,
you're a beautiful story.
And thank you for joining us.
- Thank you for having us, the blessing.
- Oh man. Absolutely.
- Hey, Wait a second
guys. I didn't leave yet.
Kelly, do you mind?
- No, not at all.
Yeah, I'll just be over here.
- Thank you. Real quick
to Troy and his kids, man.
I can't get out of here without
giving you guys something.
So I'll match what they gave, all right.
You got 50 coming from
Kevin Hart himself as well.
- What?
- You guys.
I wanna see you guys happy.
I wanna see you guys with your spirits up.
God bless always to you.
Hey, I'm gonna give movie,
so to the rest of the world,
treat yourself a good movie.
Go watch Fatherhood, it's
on Netflix right now.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)